I have a question did you steal anything
from the set tried to get the keyboard
they wouldn't give it to me I packed it
are you sure yeah I said okay do you
want anything from the set and I said I
would like to have the Steampunk
keyboard no anything else that you would
like so I've been here five years 16
hours a day five days a week you know
six months a year I'll pay for the
keyboard if that's good
no no so what do you mean no no they
said it's it's been archived I said the
NBCUniversal archive people they're kind
of like those characters in the Harry
Potter movies that work in the bank
creatures yeah what do they call those
creatures that they come in to a set
everywhere that's been shot and with
figures have like this long it's it's
somebody somebody's kid's room right now
there was actually I wish that were the
case I wouldn't I mean if it were
actually in yes if there is a real
warehouse if it was at a kid's room okay
I get it
steal it for your kid that's stealing
for their kids they're taking it for a
corporation they hoard it know where
they put it in the warehouse and if they
put it in a warehouse and they box it up
and they put it on a shelf without a
label somebody should make a series
about that yeah I got the Tesla rifle
did you really is one made in the whole
wide world
and I got everybody to sign it and I
think you get two dollars I have I have
three syllables for him Eddie's coming
don't give him the real one oh well the
last season instead of the rubber purple
gloves because we are you know and so we
got special made purple gloves with
and you're going to on eBay the last day
I was like hey guys listen I need a
script we sign it I'm gonna keep it in
charity and you're gonna put it on eBay
and Miss working with these two well
with everyone everyone on the show
paycheck I just said it louder you would
have got the laughs career job job
security I mean you know how she knows
that everybody gum story but now that
the press is here you'll get in trouble
really at this point cancellous we were
working in the train station and I was
supposed to be kind of undercover so I
had a pair of overalls on as you
normally look guys we're over overalls
apparently like the pop the pockets you
can reach through and into your pants
pockets there's no real pockets in the
overalls and I just had like my
underwear on under there it was hot in
Toronto was it was really hot was if
that was an expansion I was I was bored
so I was like kind of stamp playing
pocket pool I realized how elongated my
scrotum was so I grabbed it and I pulled
it up and I was like pulling it out of
my pocket had an idea I walked over to
our wardrobe mistress and I was like we
have to know how their she's
so sweet weight very Canadian and she's
from shot in Canada so everything is a
little sorry sorry sorry for everything
Heather
someone left gum in these overall Perry
Perry gum that she goes no that's my
scrotum and that was the end of that
story story and that's the story I knew
yourself can do this at home he tells me
this story before I have this one
close-up
where I'm supposed to be looking at this
painting get me all pensive and
everything and he tells me the story
just before my closes own else when is a
better time welcome to the warehouse
welcome to the world so what we don't
tell you you can only imagine how bad
the stories actually are you happy with
how your characters end up oh yeah they
did it they did a great thing for us
good yeah uh you know they were gonna
cancel the show outright and and Jack
Kenny our showrunner basically said to
mark Stern if you if you cancel this
show right now your your audience's will
abandon you mark Stern runs the network
because you know already what happened
with Eureka and with some of the other
shows you know and and so they they gave
us the six episodes to wrap things up
and I
you know I was upset because the show is
getting canceled not called jack'd I was
like so what are you gonna do how you
gonna kill us all and he's like no we've
already killed everybody few times and
he's like no we've got this idea about
how we're gonna end it he he started
telling me the story and deep by the end
I was just like almost in tears I was
just like wow okay and and I think
everybody ends up where they shouldn't
be and to give him our [ __ ] marks turn
his credit because this is a public
forum and both of us would like to work
again but but know that here's the truth
he didn't have to convince mark Stern of
anything this is Mark stirring no no
created the show before there was a Jack
Kenney so I remember Ned Kelly who Eddie
but anyway anybody he was he was the one
who first got pitched it made sure it
was developed he loved to show more than
anybody the problem was it was a numbers
game and all that Jack was doing that
Mark Stern was giving him ammunition so
market go fight and mark fought a good
fight and he managed instead of asking
which is what they wanted to do is
cancel us completely after episode after
season for be Comcast and yeah so that
the multinational corporation which has
other fish to fry other fish to fry is
actually what they're called Corp
limited their fish to fry limited and so
listen it's a bean-counter game in some
sometimes ok I was cheap money was on
the screen and it was like we were mark
got said no and he he made them stay up
it was it was people staying up all
night and working the numbers and
figuring out a way so that we could how
many episodes can we do is it's five is
it four is it six is it eight and it
turned out to be six episodes that I
could think it afford to do and you got
to remember it is the most expensive
show that they've ever done in their
history more expensive than Battlestar
Galactica more expensive than Yuri come
more expensive than defiance Wow one of
the reasons that were more expensive
than Ghost Hunters no and so nothing is
more expensive in many ways spiritually
so yeah so he fought and we are thrilled
this isn't like I know we're on the
price if you got me privately I would
say is in the political statement we are
we were all touched and moved by the
fight and moved by the beautiful writing
and I think our fans I know our fans are
going to be feel a sense of completion
and a sense of continuity I'm gonna say
here here's what I think about the
ending it's like all really good stuff
that's written it's both surprising and
inevitable at the same time it's both
I'm really proud of that right